>> I'd now like to
introduce Ian Glasner,
President of the Student Body.
Ian is graduating today with
a double major in electrical
and computer engineering
and business.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Ian Glasner: Challenge.
If I could describe my Carnegie
Mellon experience in one word,
it would be challenge.
When I say challenge,
I'm not simply talking
about the first computer
engineering exam I took freshman
year, I am actually
more so referring
to the subsequent
phone call I had
to give my mom telling
her that I failed.
Things didn't exactly
start off as planned.
At the time, it felt
like Carnegie Mellon had
completely knocked me over.
But we've all learned things
here, like that 0% chance
of rain really means the weather
forecaster is just hoping it
doesn't rain.
Those days usually
end with muddy shoes
and a soaking wet
backpack, or that counting
on a Pittsburgh bus to show
up on time is a great way
to be very, very late.
By knocking us over, Carnegie
Mellon has taught us how
to get back up and
sometimes getting back
up involves drinking a Red
Bull or several cups of coffee
in the basement of
a library alone
at 2:00 a.m. on a Saturday.
[ Applause ]
We've all be there.
We've all learned.
I hope everyone brought
an umbrella today.
Everyone here today has hit
a bump in the last four years
and we've all gotten
back up after.
CMU has been a challenge, but
class of 2015, we made it.
Look around.
In less than 90 minutes,
we will all be graduates
of Carnegie Mellon University.
[ Applause ]
Today, I would like to
share with you the first
of many incredible
achievements I hope
that our class will
have as alumni.
The board of trustees challenged
our class to make a senior gift
to campus, something similar
to the Class of 1987 Room
in the Cohon University Center,
but it's easier said than done.
Asking college students to make
a donation is a tough sell,
considering many of us
have borderline or not
so borderline negative
bank accounts.
The Class of 2013
gave at a rate of 6%
and last year seniors
gave at a rate of 15%.
Today, I'd like to announce
that more than 432 members
of our class contributed.
That's well over 30%.
[ Applause ]
It's more than double last year
and it's an all-time
record for Carnegie Mellon.
In a few days, we will be
spread out across the country
and the world just like
we were four years ago.
Let's not make this the
last time we are all
in Pittsburgh together.
Five, ten, 50 years
down the road,
remember Carnegie
Mellon University,
remember where you learned how
to get back up and keep going.
So long, Class of 2015.
May your futures be bright and
your hearts forever in the work
that we all did here together.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]